وهنالك قوات ترتكز وتسيطر على مقر
استراتيجيه وتبص بيانات حقا لداخل الاذاعه
السودانيه وانها ما زالت مسيطره وبالجانب
الاخر يعني
المدني خياراتهم بسيطه جدا في عمليه
الاستمرار داخل العاصمه
للمواطنين فقط ايضا لنفهم ونقرب الصوره
ماذا يجري بالتحديد على الارض عمار اي
المراكز المنشات المناطق التي تتركز فيها
حده الاشتباكات اكثر من غيرها في العاصمه
السودانيه
يعني بحسب الوارد وبحسب
كانت في وسط الخرطوم كما هو مع انحسار الى
عدد من
القوات او الاشتباكات
يعني محيط القياده العامه للجيش ومحيط
مطار الخرطوم هما ما زالت فيهما السيطره
والاشتباكات العسكريه واضحه السيد عبد
الوهاب ذكر بالامس بان
مطار الخرطوم ومطار نياله ما زالا خارج
السيطره للقوات المسلحه في قماش كالات
وهذه تعني النقود الدعم السريع ما زالت
مستمره في هذه المنطقه منطقه القصر
الجمهوري ايضا ما زالت قوات الدعم الشريف
تحصل فيها وهنالك في وسط الخرطوم عدد من
المناطق الاستراتيجيه والمنطقه الجنوب
الخرطوم ايضا كذلك منطقه بحري تشهد سيطره
من الدعم السريع في المناطق الجيش ايضا
كذلك عددين فرقه المشافي عدد من المناطق
وهذا الاشتباك هذا يعني هذه المعارك ان
تكون داخل الاحياء خاصه منطقه شنبات
والصافئ التي شهدنا من خلالها بالامس
اشتباك ات عن داخل الاحياء ادت لعدد
الاصابات وهنالك يعني انباء داخل هذه
المناطق لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات